「どうするときだけ会員ですか?」って言っても 違うんですよ
「母がいたときはね」とか言うけど でもでも安くなってくれない
そんなちょっと行かないけど 静かなところで
前朝ごはんがとっても美味しかったな 朝がブッフェみたいになってて好きなものを取れたの
だけどコロナになった時にはやめたみたいで
そっか
「そうね、あれとあれ、食い信号で食べるところはちゃんと覚えてくる」
「このオーナーはあんまりごとってんかったです」
「こっちもそうだよ」
「うん、そう」
「あった」
「そういういろんな機械も全然使ってないから」
「全然使ってない」
「あー、これとか、ママ、ほら」
「あー、この写真は持ってる」
「あー、これ」
「これどうやって全部一緒に見るんだろう」
「うん」
「いいかも」
「うん、そう」
「これ、えっと、リキッドママ」
「これママ」
「うん」
「なんか、ママちゃんってやっぱり、ちょうどいいときを選んだろうなと思って、なんか今度あの、やっぱりプレジデントちゃんってあの、アメリカで生まれたらアメリカ人にしてあげるっていうのやめたいらしいのね」
「みんな、みんなそういう人がいっぱい来ちゃうから、かわいい」
「見て、パンチャー」
「あー、そうか」
「うん」
「いいかもいいね」
「いいね」
「これ、2000年」
「2008年」
「あー、みんなそういう人が大きくなっちゃうね」
「ね」
「なんか、めんめんと一緒に言う日本のことかな」
「うん」
「思えてるかな」
「大気」
「そうか」
「えーっと」
「うん」